françois korber délégué général de
l'association robin des lois et puis
régis le sommier grand reporter rt
france qui va lui aussi nous rejoindre
dans quelques instants une initiative
donc porté par le député cédric villani
ex marcheurs et françois ruffin de la
france info mise tout d'abord je vous
propose d'écouter cédric villani
depuis plus de dix ans julian assange
journalistes récompensés par de nombreux
prix et privés de liberté son crime
avoir fait oeuvre de vérité et
d'indépendance nous réclamons que la
france lui accorde l'asile pour la
liberté de la presse pour le respect des
droits humains
voilà françois korber délégué général de
l'association robin des lois
cela fait plusieurs mois que notre
association milite pour que les
autorités françaises accordent l'asile
politique au fondateur de wikileaks on
imagine que vous accueillez avec bonheur
ce soutien parlementaire peut-être
inattendue ça peut peser pas inattendu
du tout mais là c'est quand même ce
manque de loi
travaillons depuis plusieurs mois dans
l'ombre mais parfois avec le soutien des
médias j'ai eu l'occasion d'en parler
ici sur une demande d'asile politique on
n'a pas imaginé tout seul il faudrait
savoir qu'il ya deux sortes d'asile en
france il ya l'asile régalien qui est
l'asile qui est accordée par le
président de la république dans le passé
giscard d'estaing avait accueilli namco
bénie par exemple parce qu'il a fait de
mieux mais et donc les îles du président
il ya un autre asile qui est celui de
droit commun qu'on dépose à nostra
examiner ou pas par l'ofpra c'est ça
aussi que nous visons parce qu'on a
préparé une procédure pour le moment
venu à 5 puisse saisir leur fera s'il
préside la république voulait pas se
manifester
c'est celui là voilà là il ya un moment
historique entre guillemets mais dans ce
combat qui est pour l'instant incertain
il ya des moments de désespoir terrible
parce que soutient dassin je te rends
compte que c'est très difficile on a de
l'affection pour lui on sait qu'il était
dans les conditions les tensions
terribles on sait qu'il n'est pas très
loin de l'avion de washington mais il
est possible du possible encore
le sauver et donc on a travaillé depuis
des mois en attendant mais le volet
judiciaire parce qu'il fallait laisser
la cour statue est bon là il ya un
délibéré dans quelques semaines donc
c'est le moment d'agir au niveau de
l'opinion et des médias pour faire
passer le message ben natale à l'asile
rien à dire monsieur macron à la
possibilité demain de gracier il
viendrait pas immédiatement en france
ils étaient ils pardon s'il recevait
d'asile mais ça créerait un bras de fer
et la situation politiquement et
historiquement est extraordinaire je
vous rappelle connaît quelques problèmes
avec plus d'américains en parlait
justement avec régis le sommier qui va
nous rejoindre plus tard on va aller
ailleurs sur le travail commun quand
même ça fait plusieurs mois qu'on
appelle d'abord a effectivement jean
lassalle qui est un personnage étonnant
qu'elle centriste globalement parce
qu'on voulait surtout pas et le père de
décence john shipton avec lequel on
travaille ne voulais pas que ça
apparaisse comme de droite ou de gauche
donc on a très bien réussi on a contacté
des députés de droite de gauche dans
l'ombre c'est très long c'est du temps
il y en a beaucoup il y en a beaucoup
d'autres qui n'ont pas encore signé
l'idée étant de créer un pôle à
l'assemblée de droite ou de gauche c'est
pas une question de votre gauche une
question de liberté de droits de la
presse de lutte contre tous les
totalitarismes y compris américains et
de permettre donc une poussée suffisante
sur l'exécutif quand on a commencé
puisque la salle il ya quelques mois
fait une question orale brillante à
l'assemblée face à ce triste mise est
pas étranger à monsieur le drian qui a
lu un petit papier pour dire que nos
noms à 5g ce qu'un bon c'était assez
lamentable et à ses petits par rapport à
la grandeur du sujet donc là on a un
très bon espoir c'est que ça en braille
j'expliquerai tout à l'heure comment le
blick les réseaux sociaux peuvent nous
aider à aider ce député à être 50 puis
100 puis de sang et à faire un pot dans
les semaines qui viennent pour permettre
à à l'elysée de plier peut-être et
d'accorder l'asile politique à celle où
on va on va évidemment on repart et
michel larive où vous fait justement
partie de la quarantaine de ses députés
dont parlait monsieur qu'envers de tous
bords qui ont signé cette proposition
pour accorder l'asile politique à julian
assange
pourquoi l'avoir fait et pourquoi
maintenant enfin monsieur corbère nous
l'a expliqué yahya ce procès selon vous
surtout est ce que ça peut peser
clairement
alors madame
je voudrais vous informer que pour nous
c'est un combat historique
et il y à peu plus le moment où julian
assange a dû se réfugier d'abord dans la
passade de l'équateur nous étions déjà
partie prenante dans ce combat jean luc
mélenchon l'avait rencontrée nous avons
demandé depuis bien longtemps à ce que
la france pays des droits de l'homme
normalement et puisse accueillir ce
lanceur d'alert qu'il a que le seul tort
est d'être coupable seulement d'avoir
très bien fait son métier de journaliste
est donc à partir de ce moment là il a
en peluche - parlementaires français je
vous le dis il a aidé la france
lorsqu'il
découvre et ils diffusent au plus grand
nombre les faits d'espionnage des états
unis d'amérique en france les faits
d'espionnage
envers des chefs d'état monsieur chirac
monsieur sarkozy monsieur hollande les
faits d'espionnage économique envers
dominice de l'économie française
monsieur moscovici monsieur baroin donc
voila quand ils révèlent tout ça je
crois que la france est redevable à
monsieur assange donc la moindre des
choses qu'elle pouvait faire la france
c'est d'accueillir monsieur assange et
de lui accorder l'asile présidentielle
comme l'a dit votre interlocuteur s'il
le fallait il faudrait passer par leur
trame est la moindre des choses la
france se grandirait à
ccc les dix années d'acharnement
judiciaire poli ou politique des usa en
accueillant sur son sol
monsieur julien lachance qui nous a
grandement grandement aider monsieur
macron de là dit il faut protéger les
libertés la liberté de la presse mais
aussi la liberté des individus en 2019
monsieur moretti qu'un avant d'être
ministre et la vie on a tout de même
rappelé ce qui a permis de révéler
monsieur assange il a permis de revenus
que monsieur chirac sarkozy ce que je
vous ai dit ont été espionnées donc même
le rapporteur spécial de l'onu sur la
torture nils mazères dit il faut que je
n'ai relâchant choix libre d'une part
qu'il soit réhabilité et indemnisé pour
tous les abus et toutes leurs beats
frère et là sur laquelle il a été exposé
donc à partir de ce moment là où nous
demandons depuis bien longtemps que
julian assange puisse accueillir en
france et nous avons signé ce prix
ppr cette résolution cette proposition
de résolution
avec nous s'il vous lever parce qu'on a
on va continuer ce ce débat on va faire
entrer dans quelques instants
régis le sommier qui va nous revoir le
moral et surtout retrouver katia
technique qui a fort heureusement pour
nous retrouver de la voix katia pour les
signataires on a commencé à l'expliquer
avec nos invités ici la france se doit
d'accueillir julian assage au nom de la
liberté de la presse
voilà katia
technique donc la france accueillir
julian assange au nom de la liberté de
la presse katia
allô
oui en effet puisque les députés
estiment que la liberté d'expression
tout comme la liberté individuelle sont
bafoués il cite d'ailleurs des propos d'
emmanuel macron tenue en 2019 qui
incitait à protéger ses libertés alors
il rappelle également utilement que j'ai
des changes est un allié de la france
car elle a révélé l'espionnage de
l'elysée concernant notamment françois
hollande nicolas sarkozy encore des
ministres de l'économie et les estime
que le crime qui lui vaut aujourd'hui
cet acharnement judiciaire 1 10 ans de
déboires c'est d'avoir pratiqué son
activité de journaliste d'avoir faire de
vérité et donc il mentionne également
une figure incontournable dans ce
dossier eric dupond moretti qui fut un
temps avant de devenir garde des sceaux
était l'avocat français de dullin
assange il s'étonne bien sûr du silence
de la france dans ce dossier notre pays
étant toujours très prompt à défendre la
liberté d'expression alors les
signataires vous en avez parlé un cédric
villani pour la france insoumise très
nombreux députés françois ruffin matile
panneaux adrien quatre ans et puis
également jean lassalle député liberté
territoire et même pierre alain raffin
de la république en marche donc tout une
grande partie de l'échiquier politique
et katia julian assange qui attendons
toujours la décision de justice un
britannique après donc la nouvelle
demande d'extradition des états unis
oui absolument la semaine dernière
c'était l'audience en appel de la
demande d'extradition formulée par les
américains un appel qui s'est révélé
finalement ubuesque puisque leur
président le représentant pardon des
états unis s'est ingénié à garantir que
du assange aurait de très bons
traitements en prison les décrivant
presse comme un séjour en vacances alors
que je rappelle qu'il risque 175 ans de
prison et que les états unis finalement
peuvent prendre toutes les décisions
qu'ils veulent concernant due à un
échange même l' isolement même si le
représentant prétendait le contraire et
puis surtout côté américain on s'est
employé à nier le risque suicidaire chez
julian assange alors que l'éminent
expert psychiatre qui l'a examiné qui a
produit un rapport a dit que du la
nation je risquais d'attenter à sa vie à
n'importe quel moment et même pas si
quelque chose de grave arriver mais que
le risque suicidaire était permanent et
il se trouve que la loi britannique
interdit formellement toute extradition
en cas de risque suicidaire et la
réponse sera donnée concernant cette
demande d'extradition en appel dans
quelques semaines merci katia technique
qu'on a enfin réussi à joindre ça fait
plaisir quand ça marche quand même un
régis le sommier grand reporter arte
france qui nous rejoint sur ce plateau
françois cambert commencé à l'évoquer
avec michel larive c'est vrai que ça se
fait dans un contexte un petit peu
particulier de rapport pour le moins
compliquées avec les etats-unis en
timing donc quasi parfait pour cette
proposition française écoutez c'est une
proposition française kiwis qui
honorerait la france c'est une évidence
parce qu'il faut voir il faut revenir
remonter aux sources
on a parlé de deux j'ai vu que qui ont
été évoqués les divers
comment
personnalités espionnées par les états
unis ce que ce que je vais en assange a
permis justement de montrer mes du
bien-être sans ya pas que ça devienne
assange moi personnellement c'est la
personne qui m'a révélé la première fois
en 2011 à travers un certain nombre de
documents comment
provenant de l'armée américaine le
véritable état de la guerre en
afghanistan à cette époque moi je
couvrais cette guerre comme
correspondant de paris match gta très
souvent sur le terrain avec les soldats
américains et j'ai remarqué que un
certain nombre d'actions avaient
effectivement revêtez des cô tes
proches du crime de guerre c'était pas
systématique je peux pas le dire mais
est ce que magma confirmé julian assange
à travers ces documents ces quelques
soixante quinze mille documents qui
étaient des rapports finalement fait par
les officiers c'est que cette guerre
c'était une une un maillage de tout un
tas d'incidents comme ça qu'ils
n'étaient pas du tout en accord avec le
comportement vous savez aux états unis à
le soldier the book qui a il ya le
comment là ce qu'on doit faire et ce
qu'on doit pas faire et cette guerre
avait pris une telle dérive que eh bien
il y avait
d'abord les soldes a été mis dans un
stress absolument incroyable en ayant en
devant justement reconquérir des champs
de mines et des dans lesquelles ils
perdaient un certain nombre de leurs
camarades
il y avait une intensité sur le terrain
dont nous n'étions les témoins est ce
que montrait les rapports d'assange
c'était la vérité sur l'ensemble de la
guerre or il faut rappeler qu'à l'époque
cette guerre d'afghanistan était vendu
au public américain arrive au monde
entier comme une opération de progrès en
progrès si on permanence il y avait un
certain nombre de sénateurs qui étaient
américains qui allait sur le théâtre de
guerre en afghanistan et qui à qui on
montrait on disait voilà ça y est on a
guère on a réussi à sécuriser telle ou
telle région et donc voilà donc la
assange
a contribué à révéler l'ampleur du
désastre il l'a fait aussi avec la
guerre en irak qui en plus était une
guerre qui a été comment dire bâti sur
des mensonges à la base et je pense que
si ça ce n'est pas la recherche de la
vérité je me demande ce que c'est et si
la personne qui a fait ça est
aujourd'hui accusée d'espionnage par les
états unis je dirais que même à l'époque
de comment de nixon quand carl bernstein
et bob woodward ont enquêté sur le
scandale du watergate
eh bien ils sont allés jusqu'au bout et
le gouvernement américain est tombé donc
on les arts la mis en prison à l'époque
en disant attention de l'espionnage et
ça risque de nuire à la nation
américaine de classer la france par dont
régis de vous couper mais c'est vrai que
vous êtes 3 et que on a malheureusement
peu de temps encore la question à la
france doit-elle accueillir julian
assange c'est ce qu'on vous a posé vous
avez été d'ailleurs très nombreux à
réagir alain tu nous dis un pays qui a
mis dans sa devise liberté égalité
fraternité sur les cohérent en offrant
l'asile et la liberté à un journaliste
étranger
clairement qu'il n'a commis que le crime
de divulguer des informations véridiques
j'ai la suite du message sur ma tablette
françois corbère certains vous diront
puisque moi j'ai entendu ici même sur ce
plateau que finalement julien assange
c'est aussi en voilà un qui s'est rendu
deux du crime coupables du crime de
divulguer des secrets défense de pays on
l'a entendu ici même qu'est ce que vous
répondez à 7 je vais pas faire un cours
de droit parce que j'invite ceux qui
s'intéressent à les shows les sites
complètement public ces états où tout
l'acte d'accusation bon on l'a accusé
leur fait de l'espionnage mais plus
précisément d'avoir mis en danger c'est
ça le de la sphère plus président
d'avoir mis en danger
des sources de la mecque dans la
pratique moi je suis les deux procès
l'un à londres et ici je n'ai plus eu de
loin les amis qui étaient là qui suivent
tout ça n'est absolument pas établie
nulle part à telle enseigne d'ailleurs
que dans l'ombre les américains font
savoir que si par hasard ils
n'obtiennent pas l'extradition de julian
assange dans les semaines qui viennent
il pourrait revenir à la charge avec
d'autres accusations qu'ils ont gardé
sous le coude pourquoi parce que ces 105
wikileaks je crois c'est important de le
dire aux gens qui ont moins de 40 ans
qui s'est déjà vieux wikileaks a fait
dix ans moi je vois sur le terrain on a
du mal à huy à 5a qui sait mais c'est un
qu'est ce qu'on peut faire en tant que
militante
pour convaincre il faut d'abord faire
qui est enceinte donc effectivement
d'avoir un journaliste c'est un lanceur
de l'air est évidemment que tout
journaliste à partir du moment où il
révèle un secret médical le secret
d'état secret militaire peut être
accusée d espionnage mais c'est c'est là
l'enjeu au delà de l'homme qui est
actuellement alors à l'instant par une
prison de haute sécurité en train de
crever de froid de misère c'est ça la
prison c'est bercy deux heures de vol de
paris au delà de l'humanité envers cet
homme il ya le
le côté symbolique important parce que
si jamais les américains gagnent et je
suis pas farouchement obsessionnellement
anti américains ils ont fait des choses
formidables américain mais dans ce cas
là ce n'est pas acceptable c'est
scandaleux parce que s'il gagne il
arrive à mettre à singe dans un avion
pour washington c'est à dire une prison
de haute sécurité avi il y aura plus de
journalisme possible on le voit
d'ailleurs des réticences dans les
médias oui mais bon je l'aï devrait bien
l'oublier mais ils n'auront plus cette
liberté parce que n'importe quel lanceur
d'alert demain ou dans quinze jours
n'importe quelle personne qui dans une
armée dans un étang meira des choses
scandaleuses n'osera plus le révélait en
voilà ce qui m'est arrivé donc on ne
peut pas laisser passer ça quant aux
autres d'accusation contre 5 vous en
avez fait litière vous n'en parlez pas
elles sont balayées des accusations
demeurent ce qu'on allait contre lui
tout ça a été dit reste accusations
d'espionnage qui est assez floue et qui
n'est pas établie pour l'instant
justement sur cette question
internationale il ya eu pas mal de
réactions je vous laisse les découvrir
celle des ricains la france comme
beaucoup d'autres pays devraient
accueillir assange mais comme elles s'y
relais botte des usa elle ne le fera pas
autre réaction celle de dell fin moi je
pense qu'elle doit accueillir vu la
rupture du contrat des sous marins la
france doit aussi gagner
diplomatiquement sur les états unis
michel larive on le voit il ya une voie
là l'agenda coïncide on en parlait avec
vous tout à l'heure aussi une façon est
une occasion de faire aussi un pied de
nez aux états unis de réaffirmer
l'indépendance de la france
oui alors je répète comme
ici sur votre antenne que dont jean luc
mélenchon la france a remis ça fait dix
ans que le combat dure depuis que les
problèmes de monsieur assange eux
en sont survenus derrière au niveau de
la france est au niveau de ses alliés
effectivement quand on a des alliés
comme ceux qui nous ont dernièrement
mis quand même dans des situations
extrêmement délicate notamment
des secteurs industriels entré chez nous
dans les positions extrêmement délicate
quand on a des années comme ça des fois
on se pose la question qui en a vraiment
besoin d'ennemis donc
nous avons nous maintenant je crois à
retrouver comme les grands hommes d'état
français l'avaient fait avant une
liberté une diplomatie et retrouver une
place dans le concert des nations il
était celle de la france avant que ce
sarkozy se range derrière tous les
atlantistes du monde et donc notamment
derrière la sphère des chemins la
première des choses à faire c'était de
sortir de l'otan s'étaient c'était de
retrouver sa liberté son indépendance
politique stratégique militaire voilà ce
qu'il fallait faire enfin ce que je dis
là c'est pas nouveau je viens le général
de gaulle l'a fait en son temps
d'autres l'ont fait et depuis
effectivement nicolas sarkozy la france
s'aligne sur les sur des positions
extrêmement atlantiste et le verrouiller
toutes ces possibilités mais c'est pas
seulement les possibilités géopolitique
ses possibilités géopolitiques ont des
conséquences énormes sur
la vie des gens en france c'est à dire
sur l'emploi sur les industries sur les
accords que nous passe ton
c'est à dire que je crois que nous nous
quand nous nous coupons une partie du
monde en étant très atlantiste
effectivement il y a des lois qui sont
et qui valent pour certains états et qui
ne va pas qu'ils ne veulent pas pour
d'autres la l'espionnage et le bourg eux
c'est à dire que les screeners lui va
condamner la personne qui a révélé
quelque part son crime c'est ça c'est
extrêmement de la brique écouter un peu
cette façon de penser quel monde voulons
nous est ce que nous voulons lancer
enfermer les lanceurs de l'air est ce
que nous voulons en faire mais les gens
qui sont épris de liberté ou est ce que
nous voulons effectivement l'homme
donnait la possibilité mais moi je
serais même pour un droit international
des lanceurs de l'air
il faut protéger les journaux on va
passer par dany mois par année si les
réponses sont longs on va pas réussir
malheureusement françois korber ruiz
ouvrière est et vous disiez il faut le
faire maintenant d'ailleurs mais je
tiens à vous préciser c'était pas
pourquoi maintenant venant de la france
insoumise 1 pourquoi maintenant cette
composition doit de tout bord parce que
c'est vrai que ça peut interroger il ya
même des gens de la majorité qui ont
signé cette proposition c'est que vous
êtes un combat de longue haleine pour la
france un sommet depuis longtemps oui un
mot sur cette affaire signatures pour
vous dire ce qu'il découvre le sujet ce
soir qu'ils connaissent pas forcément
très bien simple qu'est ce qu'on peut
faire et qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire
demain et dans les jours qui viennent
parce que ça peut se jouer il ya une
vieille phrase de lénine battre lni mais
qui dit qu' il y aurait suffi de
quelques hommes décidés à
saint-pétersbourg en octobre 17 et la
face du monde en eût été changée je
crois que c'est profondément vrai on
n'est pas très nombreux mais on peut
être très actif et intelligemment actifs
et l'occasion ce soit est formidable
avec en s'appuyant bien sûr sur la
signature de ses députés il n'y a pas de
secret on n'a pas de fortune cachée on
est aux ordres de personne en ce qui
concerne robin des lois et les quelques
amis qui a travaillé avec moi depuis
quatre cinq mois dans l'ombre pour
appeler les députés un par un ce travail
de chien je vous passe le détail et nous
avons tenu bien sûr que la france a
soumis là depuis le début nous allons
travailler en liaison majorité bien sûr
on a travaillé en liaison avec le père
d'assad je vais d'ailleurs mieux john
shipton qui téléguident toute la défense
travers le monde entier est un bonhomme
assez extraordinaire qui nous a dit
voilà il faut créer un groupe central
mais ça veut pas dire centriste donc
qu'est ce qu'on a fait j'étais le
téléphone pour joindre monsieur lagarde
que j'ai pas eu mais qui avait dit qu'il
était pour l'asile on a passé un temps
fou député votera bien bien sûr les
députés de la france a soumis on les a
pas tous eu on a happé députés de droite
ça donne ça bon on attend dé nous on
n'était pas prévenu de sa sortie mais on
attendait le l'occasion c'était la fin
du procès parce qu'il fallait pas
parasiter ce qu'on a fait avant le
procès c'est dans cette même esprit très
très universaliste jeu tu as quand même
il faut aller vite comme un élu cgt il
ya deux choses moi je vais vous écoutez
je crois quand on milite faut toujours
de dire aux gens comment vous faites
première chose si vous voulez donner un
coup de main vous appeler demain apd
dans la semaine où étaient les autres
députés c'est très facile sur le site de
l'assemblée nationale et vous leur dites
est ce que vous signez la proposition de
résolution et faire un retour pour qu'on
sache quel député est prêt à faire des
choses avec nous ça c'est la première
chose c'est très simple bien sûr nous
faire un retour nous téléphoner que ce
soit robin des lois ce soit à nos amis
qui gravitent autour parce qu'on est on
n'est pas dans nos petits couloirs on
est complètement
universaliste et surtout je voudrais je
crois que c'est le plus important vous
pouvez écrire pendant un public ça peut
servir j'ai des milliers de gens qui
écrivent dresser les gouttes d'eau qui
sont que les choses basculent je demande
solennellement personnellement ce soir
au nom des millions de gens en france
qui sont pour à monsieur macron
d'accorder l'asile à julian assange
l'asile régalien c'est à dire qu'il a le
pouvoir d'accorder la ville les anglais
le d'horizon il al'occasion
politiquement de faire un coup
formidable on est en bisbille avec les
américains justement régis le sommier
pardonnez moi est-ce que emmanuel macron
va le faire c'est ce qu'il va répondre à
cet appel selon vous est ce que ce
serait justement un bon coup politique à
jouer par rapport aux états unis dont on
parle et si on prend la dimension
géopolitique de cette affaire et pas
simplement la dimension humaine qui a
été bien défini et qui est scandaleuse
en effet et même le l'imbroglio
judiciaire dans lequel se trouve julian
assange aujourd'hui je dirais qu'il y
avait effectivement un coup à jouer il
ya toujours un coup à jouer
mais comme on le sait déjà été dit tout
à l'heure le silence de du garde des
sceaux on sent bien que au niveau du
gouvernement il n'y a pas de volonté
justement de ceux de s'opposer d'une
quelconque façon aux américains en dépit
de ce qui a été fait je rappelle sur la
sphère des sous marins on avait entendu
jean yves le drian parler de trahison
emmanuel macron demander des actes en
dehors d'une poignée de main et d'une
d'une accolade et 2 on a dit oui joe
biden s'est excusé en fait j'ai pas du
tout entendu des excuses moi quand
j'entends excuses en anglais c'est oui
un sens oui j'ai pas entendu aux world
series il a dit que les américains
avaient été maladroit bon c'est pas des
excuses ça est en réalité
l'insultent elle est là la france est
dans une position diplomatique
extrêmement délicate en ce moment pas
que simplement sur sur ces questions de
dossiers en afrique et dans pas mal
d'endroits dans le monde si la france
veut continuer à exister il faut qu'elle
ok qu'est lequel lequel marque sa
différence et je pense que
symboliquement pour un pays qui
professent des valeurs justement de 2
comment de défense justement de ces
droits de défense le premier droit le
première expression de la liberté c'est
la liberté de la presse est ça la
liberté d'informer la loi de 1881 donc
c'est elle est souveraine cette liberté
et là on à l'incarnation de quelqu'un
qui est allé jusqu'à sacrifier d'une
certaine façon pour informer même s'il a
commis des actes mais il a commis des
actes qui montrent la vérité sur un
certain nombre de dossiers et je pense
que la wii la france s'honorerait en
faisant ce geste on arrive encore que
l'affront de khyber france va présider
l'europe oui alors quelque peu de temps
donc ça serait une fenêtre pour jeu pas
de sympathie particulière pour toi
public ni d'hostilité j'attends qu'il
fasse quelque chose bon il se serait il
se grandirait de gaulle aurait fait ça
les gars vont donner la transition cher
françois cambert zizou qui nous dit si
la france d'aujourd'hui était encore
celle du général de gaulle justement
alors assange il serait sûrement déjà et
en sécurité mais cette france a disparu
michel larive le le mot de la fin pour
vous ça correspond à votre pensée ce
petit message de nos téléspectateurs
alors écoutez c'est ce que je vous ai
dit avant dans ma précédente
intervention du pape je suis pas plus
beaux liste que ça mais il faut bien
reconnaître que au niveau de
l'indépendance et de la place de la
france dans le monde le général de
gaulle savait y faire et je pense que on
a
tels que qu'est ce que le son à activer
de ce qu'il avait fait et je vous le
redis c'est important pour la place de
la france dans le monde c'est à dire
qu'aujourd'hui j'ai entendu parler d'
insulte à la france par les américains
notamment mais c'est vrai et les anglais
sont en ce moment en train de faire un
bras de fer avec la france parce qu'ils
sentent qu'ils peuvent le faire les
allemands sont en train de nous
dépouiller haut niveau par exemple de
l'industrie spatiale
parce qu'ils sentent qu'ils peuvent le
faire nous sommes là dans un moment de
faiblesse diplomatique énorme le
quinquennat de chamakh oms a été le
l'écroulement de la france au niveau
diplomatique est alors cet écoulement de
la france au niveau diplomatique a des
conséquences dramatiques sur le
territoire national sur l'emploi sur la
vie des gens et ça c'est je crois que là
on a peut-être quelque chose à dire
franchement la france s'honorerait se
grandirait d'accueillir ce monsieur qui
l'a défendue donc à partir de ce moment
là on a la possibilité quelque part de
redorer notre blason et de reprendre
quelque part une place sur nos valeurs
sur la ligne sur nos valeurs de liberté
d'égalité et de fraternité et sur la
valeur la valeur de ce cas c'est le
message relayé par lesquels arrivent sur
des vous le trouverez sur tous les bons
sites c'est ce tu appelles des députés
je vous dis dans les jours qui viennent
prenez un quart d'heure pour appeler
votre député de n'importe où dans
monsieur le député vous demande de
signer ce document aussi parce que voilà
vous avez passé de messages en tout cas
merci françois korber remercie michel
larive merci registre sauvier
pardonnez-nous pour ce début un petit
peu chaotique du voile à un petit point
de techniques de de son mais nos invités
voilà ont été rapides à arriver sur ce
plateau merci à vous